today we're talking about cloud adoption
data analytics training and graphql i'm
ryan and welcome to this week in cloud
where we serve you the lowest latency
news
google cloud commissioned coalition
greenwich to serve a 102 institutional
capital markets professionals to
understand the dynamics behind their
rapid adoption of cloud technology and
found that the demand for easier
accessibility was a huge factor check
out the blog for more insights and our
top 5 takeaways
bigquery is a fully managed enterprise
data warehouse that helps you manage and
analyze your data with built-in features
like machine learning geospatial
analysis and intelligent caching for
business intelligence to help you make
the most of bigquery we're offering no
on-demand training opportunities
including how to use bigquery with
looker and machine learning
check out the blog for more details and
links
picking the right api style completely
depends on your use case and graphql is
a query language for apis and a runtime
from fulfilling those queries with your
existing data
developers are increasingly adopting it
for its flexibility and ease of use and
we're excited to announce that apogee
api management platform natively
supports graphql apis allowing
developers to productize and manage
their life cycle in apogee check out the
blog for more information
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us we'll see you
in the cloud